Gaming Videoplattformen Computerdaten in
der Cloud ihr Energiebedarf ist gewaltig
und wächst stetig auf Rechenzentren
entfallen inzwischen drei Prozent des
deutschen Stromverbrauchs Tendenz
steigen
pro Minute werden im Internet zum
Beispiel alleine 28.000 Netflix Videos
gestreamt fast 700.000 Instagram Stories
geteilt oder 69 Millionen Nachrichten
versendet
die smarte neue Welt hat ihren Preis
aber wie kann der Energiefresser
Internet künftig grüner werden
insta Wanger an der norwegischen
Westküste gibt es bereits ein
klimafreundliches Rechenzentrum
die Firma Green Mountain hat es hier
2009 gebaut in einem ehemaligen NATO
Munitionslager
auf
22.600 Quadratmetern werden hochsensible
Daten aus aller Welt gespeichert torkelt
vorlaut ist für die Nachhaltigkeit bei
Green Mountain zuständig
begann mit der Idee das nachhaltigste
Rechenzentrum der Welt zu bauen
und mit dieser Anlage in renaissoi und
dieser berganlage und unserer Kühllösung
haben wir das geschafft
die Cloud ist wirklich etwas sehr
spannendes und sie ist hier
die Cloud ist das Herz jedes
Rechenzentrums jetzt konzentrieren wir
uns darauf die Cloud zu grün wie möglich
zu machen
die Cloud in die immer mehr Firmen ihre
it-auslagern wird auf Servern
gespeichert die erzeugen viel Wärme
damit die Festplatten nicht überhitzen
müssen sie gekühlt werden
remountain bietet eine sogenannte
kolocation an das heißt die Firma stellt
die Räumlichkeiten und Server zur
Verfügung manche Kunden sind nicht mal
bekannt sie wollen lieber anonym bleiben
aus Angst vor Industriespionage
die Anbindung von Rechenzentren ist sehr
wichtig der südliche Teil Norwegens ist
jetzt wirklich gut mit Kontinentaleuropa
und Großbritannien verbunden wir haben
zum Beispiel ein neues Glasfaserkabel
von hier der Westküste Norwegens bis
nach Newcastle gelegt Anbindung und
Übertragungszeiten sind also wirklich
kein Problem mehr
und die Nachfrage wächst ständig nicht
nur durch Handys oder Streaming auch der
Gewerbe und Dienstleistungssektor und
die Industrie brauchen immer mehr
Rechenleistung allein in Deutschland
gibt es bereits rund 3000 Rechenzentren
[Musik]
viele deutsche Unternehmen gehen nach
Norwegen unter ihnen Großkonzerne wie VW
auch aus finanziellen Gründen denn die
Strompreise sind hier niedriger dazu die
gute digitale Infrastruktur und kühle
Temperaturen die eine energieeffiziente
Kühlung der Server möglich machen
[Musik]
aber wären solche grünen effizienten
Rechenzentren nicht auch in Deutschland
möglich
wir treffen Tillmann santarius er ist
Experte für nachhaltige Digitalisierung
an der TU Berlin auf Rechenzentren
entfallen inzwischen drei Prozent des
deutschen Stromverbrauchs Tendenz
steigend denn die Anzahl der
Rechenzentren nimmt laufend zu zwar sind
Rechenzentren in den letzten Jahren im
Schnitt 10 bis 15 Prozent pro Jahr
Energie effizienter geworden aber weil
eben die datenverkehre so stark
ansteigen und die Cloud laufend wächst
wurde insgesamt der Energieverbrauch
nicht zurückgefahren und Szenarien gehen
davon aus dass er auch noch weiter
ansteigen wird trotz
Effizienzsteigerungen
der Energieverbrauch von Rechenzentren
wird sich voraussichtlich von zehn
Terawattstunden in 2010 bis 2025 auf 20
Terawattstunden verdoppeln
im einstein-center in Berlin sucht die
Expertenrunde um Tillmann santarius nach
alternativen ökostrom ist eine Lösung
eine weitere man nutzt die Abwärme der
Server und spart damit an anderer Stelle
Energie was gerade diskutiert wird ist
das mindestens 30% der Abnahme von neu
zu bauenden Rechenzentren genutzt werden
soll das halte ich für zu wenig
ambitioniert es gibt jetzt schon
Datenzentren die nutzen 50% der Abwärme
oder mehr so wie das norwegische
Unternehmen Green Mountain hier wird an
einem bisher einmaligen Projekt
gearbeitet eine Hummer fahren soll bald
mit der Abwärme des Rechenzentrums
betrieben werden
das Meerwasser hat eine
Durchschnittstemperatur von 8 Grad durch
die Abwärme der Server im Rechenzentrum
wird das Wasser auf 20°c
engmaschig zu überwachen und die
Fortpflanzung zu fördern
das hier ist ein Hummer Weibchen mit
Eiern auf der Unterseite wir haben für
die Eier wenn Sie hier auf der Farm
ausgebrütet werden eine viel höhere
überlebensrat als im Meer und da wir
immer etwa 10% der Jungtiere wieder
freilassen haben wir damit die
Population um mehr als 100 Mal erhöht im
Vergleich zur Fortpflanzung im Meer
an ist mit dem Boot unterwegs
er fängt erwachsene Tiere die er für die
Zucht braucht
genau hier wird er später einige
Jungtiere aus der Zucht wieder aussetzen
dieser Ort ist besonders geeignet wegen
seiner Winkel und Steine das mögen die
Hummer sehr
die felsigen unterwasserreliefs liefern
eigentlich ideale Lebensbedingungen für
Hummer
Umweltverschmutzung und Klimawandel
machen aber auch dem Hummer zunehmend zu
schaffen
ohne die regelmäßigen Auswilderungen
drohen hier die Bestände zu verschwinden
für den Meeresbiologen asbjörn ist es
ein win-win-modell hummerzucht und
gleichzeitig werden Natur-
[Musik]
dieses Projekt ist ein perfektes
Beispiel für ein Wirtschaftskreislauf so
müssen wir keinen Strom aus dem Netz
beziehen sondern erhalten die Wärme
direkt aus dem Rechenzentrum
die Menschen verstehen das Grundprinzip
das hinter der Nutzung von Abwärme für
die Lebensmittelproduktion steht und wir
wollen herausfinden wie wir die Symbiose
von zwei unterschiedlichen Industrien
kombinieren und nutzen können
Energie sind voll nutzen Norwegen macht
es vor wie Datenzentren grüner werden
können denn der Bedarf steigt
die gaming-messe DreamHack in Hannover
eine der größten in Deutschland
34 Millionen Deutsche spielen inzwischen
regelmäßig Computerspiele die Entwickler
schaffen immer neue virtuelle Welten
Grafiken und Effekte werden immer
komplexer und dafür wird Rechenleistung
gebraucht
[Applaus]
die gamerszene ist dabei weltweit
virtuell vernetzt auch das frisst
Energie doch inzwischen tut sich was
ich glaube das Green Gaming so langsam
mit der Branche ankommt auf jeden Fall
gerade jetzt im Zuge der Energiekrise wo
jeder solche Gedanken darüber machen
muss wie kann ich Drogen sparen wie kann
ich aber auch Geld sparen weil das eine
große Rolle spielt viele Menschen es ist
natürlich so dass der Computer oder die
Konsolen unsere Arbeitsgeräte sind und
wir natürlich nicht so eine große Wahl
haben aber das hat sich in den letzten
Jahren auf jeden Fall gewandelt dass
diese Grafikkarten aber auch Bildschirme
immer weniger Strom verbrauchen und
einfach immer effizienter werden
Maria Wagner ist seit Jahren
passionierte gamerin ihre Mission die
Branche grüne machen das Bewusstsein
verändern mit Klima bezogenen Games
Inhalten und nachhaltiger Produktion
[Musik]
ich habe einfach gemerkt dass das Medium
Games eine unendliche Reichweite hat und
es verbindet Menschen einfach ja global
über Grenzen
entstehen Kulturen und auch lifestyles
und das ist natürlich ein super Power
die man auch nutzen kann um was
sinnvolles zu machen
Spiele können das Verhalten von Menschen
verändern sie machen Spaß und sie
bringen Menschen dazu sich mit Themen
auseinanderzusetzen und wir dachten uns
einfach wie kommt man am schnellsten an
die drei Billionen Spieler die ist ja
auf also im Grunde spielt ja die Hälfte
der Welt ähm Spiele tatsächlich achten
immer mehr Gamer darauf wie viel Strom
sie verbrauchen natürlich nicht nur
wegen des Klimas auch die Kosten spielen
eine große Rolle
auf die Frage achten Sie beim Kauf von
Gaming Hardware stärker auf den
Stromverbrauch antworteten immerhin 21%
der Gamer mit Stimme er zu und 17% mit
stimme voll zu
[Musik]
die Themen Nachhaltigkeit und Energie
sparen sind in der Branche grundsätzlich
angekommen
[Musik]
es geht immer um das wie ich meine hier
wird super viel Energie verbrannt aber
das Wichtige ist dass man schaut wie
kann man das in der Zukunft nachhaltiger
gestalten
ja ich habe mich lange dem verweigert
und eigentlich beim haupttelefon ist
immer noch dieses Gerät ja und in dem
Moment wo ich Sachen bewusst Einsätze
und eben mich jeden Tag mache und das
ist jetzt der einmalige Sache weil wir
heben die Green Hack mal in Hannover
haben und da dachte ich könnte das für
meine Schüler im Stream einfach mal tun
ähm mache ich das einfach mal obwohl mir
eben bewusst dass das eben so dran hängt
an Energie verbraucht grüner spielen das
Bewusstsein wächst und doch stellt sich
nicht nur auf Gaming messen die Frage
wie viel Geräte wie viel Rechenleistung
und damit wie viel Strom am Ende
wirklich nötig sind für ein digitales
Leben wie viel Digitalisierung braucht
ich für ein zufriedenes Leben aber ohne
politische Standards und ohne Vorreiter
Unternehmen die aufzeigen wie es geht
wird es nicht funktionieren
bei Familie reimisch in München ist der
Alltag digital auch in der Küche
Alexa
was ist 50 geteilt durch 6
50 geteilt durch 6 ist ungefähr 8,3333
Alexa was ist 8,33 mal 8
8,33 x 8 ist 66,64
[Musik]
ob der Austausch mit Sprachsystemen die
multifunktionale Küchenmaschine oder das
Match auf der Spielekonsole überall wird
Strom verbraucht wie viel tatsächlich
wissen die meisten Nutzer nicht auch die
Familie von Nina Reinisch ist da keine
Ausnahme unten wird gezockt oben
gestreamt in bester Auflösung
mit der Zunahme der Bildschirmgrößen
steigt auch der Energieverbrauch ein 55
Zoll Bildschirm verbraucht im
Durchschnitt etwa doppelt so viel wie
ein 32 Zoll Gerät
das viel Energie von der Größe der
Bildschirme habe ich noch nie gehört
dass das von der Größe der Bildschirme
abhängig ist wie viel Energie man
verbraucht
also wenn es so ist dann sage ich meinen
Kindern sofort dass Sie bitte Ihre Filme
nur noch auf dem Handys schauen sollen
ja ich finde das auch echt schockierend
muss ich schon sagen
[Musik]
das geht
kannst du mir eine gute Serie empfehlen
auf Netflix peaky blinders
ist die spannend bis zum Ende ja
[Musik]
allein Streaming Dienste verbrauchen
weltweit knapp 200 Milliarden
Kilowattstunden Strom pro Jahr das ist
mehr als ganz Deutschland Italien und
Polen zusammen
in München wird derweil weiter gestreamt
auf allen Geräten
auf dem Handy meistens aber wenn er über
das iPad spielt dann ist auch so übers
ich mache übers Handy und der Macht über
das iPad häufig substituieren die
digitalen gar nicht die analogen
komplett sondern es findet Add-On oben
drauf doppelkonsum statt ja wir haben ja
alle noch die DVD-Player und und
Stereoanlagen und so weiter rumstehen
und hören gleichzeitig auf Spotify und
Stream Filme und zweitens
digital ist es einfacher zu konsumieren
wir können viel mehr Filme schauen wir
können Sie anytime schauen das heißt der
Konsum insgesamt steigt an und so werden
eben diese Einsparungen pro
Serviceeinheit in der Summe dann mehr
als aufgefressen ist findet in
steigender ökologischer Fußabdruck statt
also für mich war die Verbindung Handy
Strom eigentlich immer nur die ich ich
lade mein Handy auf und das verbraucht
Strom das aber Daten in dem Sinne auch
Strom verbrauchen
dass das hatte ich noch nicht wirklich
so im Hinterkopf ne aber wenn ich das so
höre dass das ähm dass die wirklich viel
Strom ziehen also ich so rein intuitiv
würde ich mein Handy jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen ausmisten vielleicht muss
sie das künftig gar nicht aber nur dann
wenn es bald mehr nachhaltige
Rechenzentren gibt
[Musik]
in der Nähe von Husum
Stephan Sladek ist Chef der Firma
futurecloud
sein Unternehmen hat eine ungewöhnliche
Idee umgesetzt die Abwärme seiner Server
wird dazu genutzt um auf dem Dach Algen
zu züchten
bislang kamen eben diese Algen immer aus
diesen Regionen wo sie heimisch sind das
heißt Sie müssen über 10.000 Kilometer
transportiert werden was natürlich ganz
und gar nicht emissionsfrei ist deswegen
brauchte ist eine Wärmequelle damit die
sich auch wohl fühlen also Fotosynthese
machen die ja auch ohne Wärme aber Sie
fühlen sich halt bei diesen Temperaturen
nicht wohl die legen sich quasi auf den
Boden wenn das kalt wird und wie so ein
Bär und machen Winterschlaf in
Schleswig-Holstein liegt die Temperatur
im Sommer mit 18 Grad rund 3 Grad unter
dem Bundesdurchschnitt das spart Strom
beim Kühlen der Server
so hier haben wir jetzt die Spirulina
eigen aus unserer letzten Ernte
sehr gut
leckere Ernte
schmeckt ein bisschen nussig die
Spirulina wird in der
nahrungsergänzungsmittelindustrie
eingesetzt also wir haben hier ganz bei
uns in der Nähe eine kleine Manufaktur
für
in erster Linie Hundefutter und
die Hunde können diese Alge sehr gut
aufnehmen die Algen können auch in der
Kosmetik eingesetzt werden und es gibt
bereits Studien zum Beispiel bei Airbus
dass man daraus ein Flug Benzin machen
kann
[Musik]
und auch aus einem weiteren Grund ist
der Standort ideal das Rechenzentrum mit
Algen Zucht steht auf einem ehemaligen
Militärgelände es ist Teil des greentec
Campus ein Entwicklungszentrum für
Nachhaltigkeit
im Mittelpunkt steht die Windkraft
Marken Jensen ist Gründer und Chef er
zapft mit seinem Auto direkt Strom aus
einem der kleineren Windräder
eine Umdrehung einer großen
Windkraftanlage sorgt dafür dass ich ein
E-Fahrzeug komplett aufladen kann das
sind so die kleinen Fahrzeuge wenn ich
jetzt ein Linienbus habe um mal in
größere Einheiten zu denken ich habe
jetzt einen Schulbus und kann mit einer
Umdrehung einer großen Windkraftanlage
diesen voll beladenen Schulbus 10 km
transportieren das ist mal etwas wo man
sich mal richtig vorstellen kann wie
viel Power wie viel Energie schenkt und
sozusagen eigentlich der Liebe Petrus
das Rechenzentrum läuft so mit 100%
Ökostrom
der wetterapostel und die Grünen
Datenzentren hier finden Sie zusammen
ich bin eben aufgewachsen eine schöne
Nordseeküste und die haben wir wie wir
ja sehen jede Menge Energie sondern
Energie aber vor allen Dingen auch Wind
Energie und da sind wir hier natürlich
erstmal im Eldorado logischerweise oder
wie viele sagen der Ruhrpott dazu kommt
weil wir diese Ressource sind Energie
eben hier komplett haben
Martin Jensen hat in den letzten
Jahrzehnten über 30 Windparks in seiner
Heimat gebaut
die werden gebraucht
aber oft müssen sie auch abgeschaltet
werden um eine Überlastung im Stromnetz
zu verhindern
[Musik]
wir ärgern uns extrem über die
Abschaltung weil die Netze nicht
ausreichend gebaut wurden weil wir
selber nicht genug eigenen Verbrauch
hier in Schleswig-Holstein haben wird
abgeschaltet aber eine neue Industrie
wie die Rechenzentrums Industrie die
gehört natürlich dahin wo wir eben sonst
abschalten das heißt hier natürlich in
den Norden und an die Küste erstmal den
Verbrauch dorthin siedeln wo die
Ressource einfach günstig und verfügbar
nachhaltig und sicher ist
es gibt viel Potenzial für grüne
Rechenzentren in Deutschland
[Musik]
trotzdem wandern viele ins Ausland ab
wir sind wieder in Norwegen diesmal in
der Nähe von Oslo
[Musik]
in Ringe Rieke baut die deutsche Firma
Akio Computer ein 5000 Quadratmeter
großes grünes Rechenzentrum
[Musik]
für nachhaltigkeitsmanager Carl von
Hessen liegt der Vorteil auf der Hand
hier gibt es viel grüne Energie und das
ohne deutsche Bürokratie als wir nach
Norwegen gekommen sind uns noch
Standorten umgeschaut haben sind wir auf
großes Wohlwollen gestoßen super
Beispiel ist tatsächlich der
Genehmigungsprozess der hier in Norwegen
satte 10 Tage gedauert hat wir kennen
uns auch mit den Regularien in
Deutschland aus und da dauert eine
Baugenehmigung in der Regel immer
mindestens ein halbes Jahr das ist so
der Durchschnitt mit dem wir immer
rechnen bitte Peter Kameras ist Chef der
Firma
er ist stolz auf die Möglichkeiten die
sein Heimatland Norwegen Unternehmern
wie ihm bietet
[Musik]
ja genau
wir mussten nicht springen der Boden ist
flach und sandig und wasserdurchlässig
das ist gut wenn es regnet also ein
guter Ort um ein großes Gebäude zu bauen
so jetzt
building wir sparen nicht nur Geld
sondern haben hier auch einen geringeren
ökologischen Fußabdruck als
anderswood
die Entwicklung von grünen Rechenzentren
kommt in Deutschland nur schleppend
voran
Norwegen ist da schon einen Schritt
weiter
Carl von Hessen fast zusammen
wir sind aber auch nur ein Teil der der
Gleichung am Ende des Tages muss die
gesamte Industrie daran arbeiten dann
müssen die Kunden mit ihren Servern
daran arbeiten dass sie weniger
stromfressen und sozusagen auch bis am
Ende des Tages bis zum Nutzer der
wiederum auch sich vielleicht
entscheiden muss ob er jetzt das
Katzenvideo streamt oder nicht
in Norwegen sind die Bedingungen für den
nachhaltigen Betrieb von Rechenzentren
besonders günstig hier erzeugen mehr als
25 Windparks und über 1.500
Wasserkraftwerke rund 98% des Stroms
[Musik]
in Norwegen wird der größte Teil unserer
Energie aus Wasserkraftwerken gewonnen
ich stehe gerade an einem das nur drei
Kilometer von unserem Rechenzentrum
entfernt ist und 13.000 Häuser versorgen
könnte ich denke Deutschland kann in
Sachen Nachhaltigkeit definitiv ein
wenig von Norwegen lernen aber natürlich
kann auch Norwegen von Deutschland
lernen
ich können wir das Beste aus beiden
Welten Vereinen die industrielle
Erfahrung aus Deutschland und die
Nachhaltigkeit den geringen Kohlendioxid
Fußabdruck in Norwegen und beides
zusammen zu etwas noch besseren
verbinden
[Musik]
Spieleabend bei den rheinmes in München
mal ganz analog
[Musik]
naja fast
oft versuche ich abends dass man
zumindest gemeinsam zu Abend ist oder
das halt ein Essen am Tag ist wo man
dann zusammen sitzt und da bestehe ich
dann schon drauf dass die Handys
weggelegt werden
die machen das ohne morgen
klar man muss sie dann schon irgendwie
beschäftigen ja einfach dann sagen
Handys weg und dann aber kein Wort reden
das funktioniert das nicht dann oft nach
dem Essen oder so ist dann auch so dass
wir dann sagen hey spielen wir irgendwas
und dann wird er tatsächlich ein richtig
schönes Spiel gespielt ohne Handy ohne
Internet ohne ja
eine gute Idee für das grüne Internet
reicht das allerdings noch nicht dafür
braucht es schlaue Ideen nicht nur zu
Hause sondern in der gesamten
Gesellschaft der Wirtschaft und Politik
sonst wird die Digitalisierung zum
großen Energiefresser
[Musik]
gute Nacht Jakob gute Nacht gute Nacht
Jasper gute Nacht gute Nacht Joni gute
Nacht gute Nacht mein Schatz gute Nacht
gute Nacht